quelque part je pense que ça suppose
quand même la confiance le fait que le
gouvernement délègue la gestion à une
logique assez les intérêts que de
microbes
c'est comme dans les dents de la mer je
venais dans les eaux de la mer le petit
elle est le maire de la ville veut pas
faire mais voilà les veut pas dire qu'il
ya un requin qui tue les gens parce
qu'il attend le il attend des touristes
pour le week end du 4 juillet on a envie
à ramer louvre on en vient forcément en
déduire cela quand on entend un
spécialiste dire c'est aberrant
effectivement on se dit il ya deux poids
deux mesures qu'il y ait à l'important
c'est la puissance économique et
financière des acteurs maintenant à ce
jeu là on peut aussi s'en mordre les
doigts parce que si ça va contre la
transition vers une autonomie
l'autonomie dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure puisque des détails on au marché
se seront plus des producteurs locaux
que les suisses qui ce qui va
approvisionner les supermarchés
finalement qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
politiquement pour obtenir cette
autonomie politiquement je pense que le
gouvernement a décidé de déléguer
quelque part presque la communication au
jour le jour à des spécialistes pour se
donner
de cette manière on a c'est un peu
l'antithèse de lusine de rouen lubrizol
quelque part on se disait le ministre
est un état était sur le devant de la
scène
ils ont été prompts 4 à se mobiliser
quelques heures après l'explosion et
c'est là on a l'impression que au
contraire on va dire on va donner la
parole à la délègue à des experts savez
vous pourquoi puisque dans le cadre du
brésil ça n'a pas empêché les complots
les théories du complot de prospérer et
effectivement vous avez un lieu quelque
part je verrai une sorte de tragédie
avec unité de temps et de lieu là c'est
beaucoup plus diffus
donc effectivement on a l'impression que
le on se dit que le politique et à
l'obligation de transmettre le bébé la
patate chaude si j'ose dire oh
[Musique]
ou compétence sanitaires